the most expensive belief in the world
is that there's something outside of
yourself that's preventing you from
making money you give all the power to
something outside of yourself whenever
you cast your power or blame towards
gender race zip code country whatever
you may be 100% right but it doesn't
help you at all as soon as you give that
as the reason then you give yourself the
excuse of why you're not going to get it
and then you remove all power you have
over the situation and so it is the most
expensive belief because it's the one
that costs you everything that you could
potentially have if you didn't have that
belief